great neck new york is an upscale
community on the north shore of long
island where competition among italian
restaurants is fierce troviano's has
been struggling to survive for the past
three years owned by anthony trobiano
and his girlfriend's parents they are
now just months away from losing
everything
my desire to own a restaurant basically
started right after culinary school uh
working for other people look at that
huh and then i said to myself why am i
busting my ass for everybody when i
could be doing it for myself yeah joe
put a steak knife on there and then he
came to me one day and says this place
is available you want to buy it i don't
know if it took balls or i was just
playing stupid doing it they go right
over me and ask him having a business
together you know you see too much
you're together too much there's
resentment because of it appetizers
one minute tim
i i heard you mean i think we've been
together for six years we used to never
fight ever i thought he was like the
best person in the world and then we got
here i'm like who am i going out with i
want a whole new [ __ ] slip you should
have two when it comes down to running
the business it's really anthony that
runs it hey change the [ __ ] ticket
bro come on
[ __ ] it
it's my restaurant my rules and that
should be the bottom line fire 14.
at the beginning trobianos took off
we didn't maintain the food coming out
fast enough with quality
and from there our business decreased
there will be plenty of open tables
believe me
the early bird special was my idea any
place you like it's bringing in people
to keep the boat afloat how we doing
folks everything all right forget about
it i feel like i'm in florida it's crazy
i'm working killing myself to pay bills
i don't want to live like this i don't i
don't really want to live this way
anymore it's depressing i put my parents
into this position they were finally
getting comfortable now they have no
choice but to work or they're going to
lose everything anthony
he's only my daughter's boyfriend i put
my faith i put my home
my retirement my wife's well-being
everything else on the line with this
young man
at the end of the day you know it is my
name on the awning to think that my name
is going down as well as the restaurant
that would definitely be disappointing
you guys have to run more food okay we
are
more
the last three years have been rough
by this time in my life i thought we
would have been married had kids already
if we don't get chef ramsay's help
there's no other options for us
[Music]
okay here we are oh [ __ ] it's for sale
no that's an early bird dinner menu
14.95 [ __ ] me stupid at the sub shop
right tribianos
here we are
hello hi there how are you how are you
gordon please first name is joe joe good
to see you very nice to meet you
likewise good to see you too pat nice to
see you when chef ramsay came through
that door i thought it was a blessing i
think hopefully he'll put us straight
so uh who came up with the bright idea
of opening a restaurant
you've bought a restaurant with your
future father-in-law it was just an
exciting thing you know you're able to
purchase a restaurant as a dream of mine
holding out 28 29. so you're 25 when you
opened it
which is [ __ ] young to open the
restaurant
yeah yeah i felt that was ready
ambitious you know how have you trained
in italian restaurants no i've not
i felt i knew everything i still do
are you that arrogant
possibly
i wouldn't open a [ __ ] italian
restaurant without working in one
i definitely think anthony needs to hear
that he's arrogant because i say to him
sometimes and he takes it as oh yeah you
know you know what you're talking about
i'm gobsmacked
that a young man at the age of 25 would
manipulate his future father-in-law to
open an italian restaurant having never
worked in a [ __ ] italian restaurant
that doesn't make sense no offense i
didn't pin him down and handcuff him and
said you i need your house to put the
restaurant you've got the house now
chef ramsay was you know making me feel
like it's my fault that the restaurant
ain't doing too well i have enough
pressure as it is you guys are
struggling to get married and you've
been married for a long time you know
that level of pressure how did you
manage that it's been rough because we
can't do what we want to do anymore we
just can't do it tiffany
i hated you and he'll get mad at me then
i'm saying this but i do i don't like it
here it's not that i don't like working
i like you honestly
it's just hard sometimes
i have an anthony and my parents as
partners tends to be difficult anthony
says one thing and my parents say
another and you know sometimes they
clash whose idea was with that pathetic
side of the window
me
[Music]
it's bringing some sort of customers in
right yeah
it seems everyone's in agreeance with
you know the light-hearted decisions
made by one individual what chef ramsey
had to say to anthony was on point
sitting back and just listening and you
say to yourself wow what the hell are we
doing
why do we do this
are we back here now
chef ramsay feels one way and i feel
another and at the end of the day the
name on the awning is trobianos it's not
ramses
[Music]
trobiano's has unfortunately become
known for one thing and one thing only
it's inexpensive early bird special how
are we doing that
the restaurant is only minutes away from
its nightly ritual
hello
how are you
were you early of course
put you right by the window
oh my goodness
one thing all the family agree on is
that the food is great and anthony well
he's certainly a confident guy now i may
be in for a treat and right now it's
time for the early bird
here we
go this is busy yes huh got there early
aren't they 4 30 4 30. who eats that
early right
wow
the decor matches the clientele drab
fuddy duddy yeah and seriously old
fashioned
i feel like i've come to see my granny
in a retirement home
and i can't eat dinner at 4 30 in the
afternoon
you enjoy your dinner well i'm sure what
would you recommend
the trobiano salad is excellent
it's chopped why would you chop it
people seem to love it is that because
of their teeth maybe
it must be a nightmare knife forms
right
i can't stand here
still need a few minutes i know i think
i'm ready all right what would you like
uh
first thing eggplant tower okay then
i'll have the chicken wrap shrimp please
finally
some fish what would you recommend the
salmon is fresh it comes with potatoes
and vegetables or pasta any pasta you
like but you wouldn't serve spaghetti
with the salmon yeah people get it all
the time because they like to take the
pasta home usually
let's go for the salmon it's beautiful
nice okay excellent thank you wow
two for one what up
you got it
is he sleeping over there
is he
[Music]
here we go right here table tens
appetizers please i'm very excited to
show chef ramsay what i can do i feel
that there will be no faults in what i
produce more there you go wow
the eggplant tower oh my god
when chef ramsay's advertising was
coming out you can see his face like
what is this [ __ ] i said oh my god we're
dead
that's definitely not homemade
mozzarella there's ghastly stone cold
solid and tasteless how are you madam
how was dinner
fair and what have you got in the bag
what is that
eggplant parmesan cheese oh lovely when
will you have this for lunch tomorrow
yeah so you're not coming back tomorrow
no not the moment because you've got
dinner there
i like your british accent thank you i
like your lipstick
great spending time in the company of
the golden girls
exactly
[Laughter]
kevin bring it out
wow chicken wrap shrimp thank you
chicken and shrimp when i got the
chicken and where's the shrimp
bingo
i'm talking with that looks like chicken
tastes like shrimp or [ __ ]
they are salt i've never had shrimp that
hard why would you stick a shrimp inside
a chicken
it's one of his creations i guess okay
you ready jesus oh yes thank you again
thank you
jesus
your strip was too hard rock hot like a
bullet
okay he says why would you put shrimp
inside of a chicken he says i don't get
it
all
when the right dish came back i was i
was disgusted
pissed off i wanted to prove him wrong i
wanted to show my cooking skills
you know are up to par somebody please
run this [ __ ] food
that's a bolognese thank you
thank you okay christ
i'm dry
and absolutely hideous
when his side was dry but like really
dry okay would you mind just
how would you like another piece
okay
if salmon was too dry
he don't want another piece he said this
was brutal
there you go
more taste
throw it out
when it came back i was just too pissed
off to even taste it i was furious at
chef ramsey saying that my food is [ __ ]
[Music]
personally i feel that it's the wrong
opinion at this point i'm [ __ ]
furious i'm curious
it's only 7 p.m early bird customers
have now left and at a time when
restaurants are usually bustling
trobiano's is empty all is quiet except
it's time for the family to hear from
gordon let's have a chat together
[Music]
one thing that was absolutely amazing
this evening is the size of the portions
when you serve an entree you're serving
a second entree with it it's been
confirmed to why we don't open for lunch
because you're serving the lunch
the night before so they're robbing you
however that's not the biggest problem
the food
hideous
the leaning tower pisa what what's going
on there with that the eggplant tower
what was wrong with him that's not fresh
mozzarella i'm really sorry that's
processed commercial crap
[Applause]
salmon did you see it when it went back
to the kitchen
yes i did yeah just because you may have
the
inclination and i'm acting like a dick
it was dry i don't think you're acting
like a dick i just didn't want to taste
it myself
it's hard to hear him get yelled at but
chef he knows what he's talking about so
he should listen to him every time a
plate comes back to my kitchen i taste
it
and then the worst dish the shrimp in
the chicken where'd you go looking for
the shrimp just seemed unique now i'm
even more concerned about what you're
tasting i thought you had a better
palette than the [ __ ] customers in
there this evening
it was hideous
he could bust my balls about my ego but
you should not be killing me over my
food i know i'm a great chef i don't
think he knew what he was talking about
okay i'm out of here it's been a tough
day for everybody
goodnight guys
[Music]
14.95
that's not easy that slapping a family
in the face especially when they're half
a million dollars in debt and
it's tough
i honestly don't know if i can turn this
around
oh dear
oh dear again
i don't know
we're so frustrated we're so worn out
we're so beat up we don't know what
[ __ ] direction we're going anymore
well obviously we have to find the right
direction because we're drowning
very quickly
maybe this was a godsend that he came
here
[Music]
you know what
there's no way i can sleep i'm gonna go
back to the restaurant and actually find
out what this guy's kitchen's like
what's he working with before i start
putting my plan together
as gordon ventures into the kitchen the
family continues their post-dinner
meeting you need to take criticism
better i'm gonna take criticism you're
like oh these people know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about
you don't want to hear it
right you don't want to hear it but you
have to though like you got to take it
and be like maybe i am doing something
wrong
[Music]
this
is shocking
what was the last time this was
clean inside my goodness
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
you know what you do wrong
take more control of these guys and i
feel that you don't if you want me to
take the control don't go second guess
me about anything that i do
[Music]
right behind here
oh my god
[ __ ]
look at that there that is mouse or wrap
droppings oh my god
a couple of hours ago i was feeling
slightly
embarrassed for them slightly concerned
in a big way but now
when a chef let go of his kitchen like
this it proves he doesn't care
i want to be more involved in the
business end of things forget the
business aspect and your portion is the
hosting portion
[Music]
hi there yeah
i was going back to the hotel couldn't
sleep
had a look in the kitchen
and i am absolutely [ __ ]
gobsmacked
how can you do that
when that is
that again what is that what is that
come here
[Music]
anthony how can you cook in this
when was the last time this was cleaned
a kitchen
oh we try to do it on a daily basis i
mean
what
have you seen under there
underneath underneath here
joseph would you mind having a look i
don't think you've actually seen this
down there i see it
look at that oh god please
anthony
talk to me
give me some form of feedback
don't [ __ ] me give me something
please oh they're asked to do it every
day the staff they're what they're asked
to do with everything we're on our ass
with half a million dollars debt and
you're telling me now that you don't
even clean that's what we have staff for
right
oh my god
what's this then
what's that on there the droppings
they're not [ __ ] caraway seeds
i wasn't going to wear them
i couldn't imagine it was been that bad
from the surface everything looks
nice and nice
when you start digging
i can't just can't believe it isn't this
your bedrock isn't this where it's all
created from
you can't create jack [ __ ] from here
i swear to god i don't think you give a
[ __ ]
you should be absolutely ashamed
chef ramsay came in like a bat out of
hell and again just whipped the living
crap at him
there's only so much you could do or say
it's hawaiian to me
give me something please oh my goodness
[Music]
come on with an answer anthony although
i'm [ __ ] out of here i swear to god i
am [ __ ] out of there
i can't take much more of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] it you've got no chance
[Music]
i am
[Music]
anthony's arrogance and his refusal to
take responsibility for his kitchen have
pushed gordon to his breaking point i am
out of there
when gordon ramsay walked out i said
that was it we're finished we might just
[ __ ] burn the place i don't know
you don't even want to help us
when i saw chef ramsay going onto the
street i was feeling a failure i had to
tell them how i felt and just not let
this slip through our fingers
[Music]
where do we stand
i want to get this place back
why have you given up then tell me there
must be a reason
because on the ambulance in there you
gave up years ago
anthony that's your family in there
right
and each and every one of them believe
in you yeah
don't you feel bad
honestly
don't you wake up with sleepless nights
yeah i do
i do you ever had that burden on your
shoulders somebody's house
not quite to this extent no
i've been in the industry for 21 [ __ ]
years busting my balls
i've made mistakes yeah i've had
failures but [ __ ] me
have i learned from it exactly i'm
trying to learn from it
are you yes i am
by that in there come on [ __ ] come on
[ __ ]
huh
i think you've had it too easy
[Music]
you're one lucky [ __ ] boy to get hold
of this restaurant at 25
and i don't see that [ __ ] level of
humbleness
slightly arrogant fine
but a little bit of
humility you know
forward yeah chef ramsay taught me you
need to face reality you need to realize
that maybe you're not the only one
involved in everything
time to get humble
and turn the corner
let's go
we've just had a chat and now we're
gonna clean
when that place is clean
and you see the difference you will
respect it from a completely different
level not just the kitchen
the ingredients
if that's not working
what chance have we got
let's do it together
oh [ __ ]
it's gone when i seen gordon ramsay come
back in i said okay there's still a
little ray hope
declutter everything get rid of all the
food first yeah we're going to give this
place a really good clean
at this point i'll do anything and
everything that chef ramsay does suggest
he's definitely a shot of reality he's
kind of just snapping me back into place
[Music]
after a stressful night gordon chooses
an unlikely spot to introduce the family
to the first of many changes
this is one idea okay in order to
separate
your restaurant from any other italian
restaurant anywhere near great neck what
do we get from cows
make the milk the butter yeah cheese
what do we do with milk and cheese what
do we make
mozzarella exactly
exactly that who's milked a cow before
not worse oh my god miss glamorous pat
gloves off please gucci gloves look at
those gloves
you could have prepared me a little bit
oh my god nice and gentle now make sure
your hands are warm
ah yeah
what's going on
just try and keep it in the bucket but
this was so out there to milk your own
cow i know i can really say something
but i'm the president
i'm starting to get a little excited
here i never thought i'd see my wife
milking cow she's over there playing
with the others going uh uh
come on tiffany put both hands please
nothing's going out
oh that's tiffany
i'll just squeeze it
oh my god look at this i can't believe
i'm looking at a cow
you've done that before no i just i
watch a lot of westerns
come on anthony put some muscle into
this she's running away you're not
blaming somebody else again are you come
on you're the chef
well done
[Music]
okay
on the back of last night's scenario
just bringing you four together and
having some fun was great because it
looked like a family
last night everyone was in their own
little turmoil so today was really what
we needed this now needs to be
pasteurized we'll take it back and we'll
start making our first ever fresh
homemade mozzarella ready
yeah um that was pathetic
yeah
teats
are not your strong point right
definitely let's go
back at the restaurant gordon walks them
through the process of making fresh
mozzarella anthony push all the way out
so it gets really nice and shiny perfect
there you go look that's it you've got
it i didn't know how to make vegemite
we actually had a nice little learning
experience 45 minutes a day chef
ramsay's idea to make fresh mozzarella
here is definitely putting a stamp on
trobianos it's something that people are
going to remember people going to come
for
[Music]
with a number of bookings for friday
night gordon decides it's an opportune
time to implement another one of his
changes
okay tonight
take down that sign
[Music]
the early bird's finished you don't need
it you're running a restaurant not a
retirement home let's go now that the
early bird menu is a thing of the past
gordon introduces pasta and mozzarella
specials to the dinner service okay
spaghetti lobster i don't want it
flooded with a heavy coating of tomato
sauce yeah yeah and over here homemade
fresh mozzarella yes with caramelised
red onions
escarole
bang beautiful all right two nice
specials yeah okay good
hello ladies
going into dinner service i'm real
nervous i got this buzz going on we got
a lot of things on the line here so you
want a mozzarella special yeah you can
bring them out with the appetizers
thank you
two more specials
taste tastes taste yeah
yeah i don't care if it's a [ __ ]
sauce of breadcrumbs you taste yes
[Music]
we're looking good looking good looking
good come on
the mozzarella is fresh they actually
milk the cow in himself right yeah
delicious delicious
mike spinach ravioli lots of ravioli
eliminating our early bird special is a
lot more difficult we have a lot more
dishes to prepare for i need the lobster
special we need to hurry up
please
let's go come on go go go go auntie look
at me taste you [ __ ] taste yes chef
i gotta wash my hands yeah i'm probably
gonna make a big sign i think anthony
needs it saying you have to taste the
food before it goes out oil kick his ass
okay we're coming we're coming here we
go here we go
go
mike we got a side of linguine garlic
and oil coming up
right after another
it's busy this guy's getting absolutely
slammed but he can move her he's
definitely got talent but there's one
thing this guy hasn't done is taste a
thing from a chef's point of view how
can you serve food out to the customers
and not taste anything
unacceptable beyond [ __ ] belief now
i'm locked out while anthony might not
be tasting his food the customers are
all
and they're not impressed it's all
overcooked
yes
special's tough right yeah it's dry it
seems like it's been around not
dangerous
another another fettuccine well yes
please
[Music]
he wants to look at the menu so get him
two menus
anthony table 17 they're complaining
about their food saying it's this is too
dry there's two more gentlemen said the
same thing so they're gonna look at
something else you gotta [ __ ] kidding
me
anthony you gotta taste this food come
on
now we're playing games here we're in
the business over here
we're getting killed right now
falling behind big time it's an hour
into dinner service and a kitchen that
is not used to being busy is starting to
crumble all right it's 25 minutes right
by the time i go i don't have to go to
bed
where's my potatoes
[Music]
you gotta be kidding me
anthony was definitely getting his ass
kicked tonight please get it out come on
the food was taking too long people were
scrambling because they were trying to
rush go go go go hurry up oh [ __ ]
something's burning
fire
[Music]
oh my god that's not good
anthony
with the kitchen already running behind
michael's burnt entree has brought the
dinner service to a grinding halt
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll regroup here we'll regroup okay on
a night filled with more setbacks than
successes anthony is trying to salvage
the evening by pleasing the remaining
customers
it's like nothing
i'm ashamed
of myself and i didn't think it was as
bad as the clientele found it to be you
know could be i guess blinders that i
was wearing
you're not a [ __ ] pissed i am
they think tonight was a disaster you
know it's depressing and i know we have
to change things i just don't know what
to do oh my god i'm coming out too slow
can i have to sell ticklies with the
wine
what's the matter if you please leave me
alone
please i'm i'm begging you too
tiffany and i's relationship has been
rocky the stress that we've been through
over the past three years has definitely
proved to be the breaking point if the
restaurant went to fail maybe we don't
move on maybe that's the end of our road
my god
[Music]
tonight didn't go by without his
problems
anthony from the first
place that left your kitchen to the last
plate
you
didn't taste a [ __ ] thing
you can't be that [ __ ] arrogant
it was a travesty
that is your [ __ ] job and the minute
you don't do that don't call yourself a
chef
i never really tasted things beforehand
never thought it was necessary
i guess that just comes with the cocky
and the arrogance of me you have got to
taste
if you're not tasting it what the
customer's experiencing
you know anthony should be tasting his
food he should know why the clientele is
complaining it's just hurting my
business and it's hurting my family
samora
we have to be different anthony it
separates you from being average to
something quite special
if you thought tonight was busy oh hey
god help me because we are
relaunching this restaurant tomorrow
i know it's late get some sleep a big
day tomorrow two in the morning
good night
i feel like you can't get any worse than
it is now
hopefully tomorrow is going to be a new
beginning for everybody
[Music]
in preparation for the relaunch gordon's
team worked through the night updating
troviano's stodgy interior
good morning good morning right big day
today free launch day a lot of changes
you didn't like this place when i first
arrived yeah you didn't like the decor
didn't like the lighting and it was
bland are you ready for a change yes
let's go
come through
come through out with the old in within
you oh my god holy [ __ ] it's warm
yes i couldn't believe what i've seen i
was definitely in the wrong place i was
dreaming everything was unbelievable the
chairs just the table forts the booths i
mean everywhere you look was beautiful
oh look at this that's italy on there
yes you're running an italian restaurant
so we're gonna have some authentic
italian pictures on the wall
i used to hate this place they say hey
coming in here but now with the new
decor everything just goes really well
together everything is just perfect it's
romantic it's warm and more importantly
it's sexy this is great look at this
that is the mozzarella bar wow that's
awesome are you happy happy it's good
word goodbye good man
come here
no i'm happy about crying
i just can't believe it i can't it's
more than i've ever ever expected it's
beautiful it's a total fresh start you
know we're gonna take them today and
just keep moving forward
okay good the menu absolutely crucial
we've condensed it and it's simple and
rustic
oh my god okay no more salmon and
bolognese sauce it's authentic
portions have been trimmed and they're
sensible portions he showed us the menu
it was downsized the prices were better
it's beautiful it's all in place now
tonight is where it's gotta work
i'm a little nervous for anthony this is
where he has to show what he's made of
so hopefully he can get that done
in preparation for the big relaunch
gordon introduces the staff to the new
dishes gone are the shrimp in the
chicken
and the dried out salmon in their place
authentic italian dishes the salt spicy
roasted potatoes rosemary garlic salmon
the ribeye steak and the lamb ragu
homemade mozzarella we've got hundreds
of balls of fresh mozzarella right have
a taste
wow this is good
tasty salad joe that's good oh my god
everything is so delicious
okay guys it is going to be a very
important night and it is absolutely
crucial we stay together on it
one more thing
i had a phone call from the
editor-in-chief of the bonneville team
magazine
they want to join us for dinner oh my
god i'm very nervous about tonight you
know when he just told us about the
critic coming that scares the hell out
of me this is a real chance
to put this place on the map just under
6 million people read that magazine per
month
tonight i have to make sure anthony
stays on the right track with his
cooking with his tasting of the food
everything is on the line this could be
a great opportunity for trobianos or it
could be the final nail in the coffin
how are you
good good hi how are you i'm joe how you
doing how are you doing oh it looks nice
it looks just like a manhattan typically
i just want to tell you we're trying
something new we have a mozzarella bar
here we go let's go so they've got one
each so six slices there six slices on
there
excellent c bang you have 30 seconds 80
off you go there's one for you and one
for you what this is this is delicious
another one yeah for four
can't believe how well this is gone this
is unbelievable it's extraordinary i'm
gonna fill up on the appetizer
yeah follow him behind me chicken
parmigiana coming up you're tasting the
food
please tell me you taste it taste the
[ __ ] stuff man
it's very important to keep the standard
sign we have to impress a lot of people
we got a lot of things on the line here
no i don't gotta make sure they tasted
this [ __ ] i gotta watch him now with
troviano's busier than it has been in
years the pressure is now on anthony to
keep up with the orders
but his staff must come through for him
as well
kevin table four i have no idea what
that is bro
yeah vegetables sorry danny i have two
16s does not make sense buddy what's
going on here the wait steph here is
killing anthony if you can't read the
[ __ ] thing give it back to him yeah
yes here take him rewrite it right here
quick kevin got to get these tickets
salted otherwise you're gonna get [ __ ]
in 15 minutes yes sir yes while anthony
gets the staff in line are they finished
with it so is it fired right away i need
to know
joe scans the dining room looking for
the bon appetit table any sign of one of
yeah good eyes open yeah tony yeah start
pushing out these entrees now yeah
you're on top of it you're staying on
top of it
done
yeah
that's okay
all right
enjoy wow
yeah why can't i make fish like this
please watch that you have potential
yeah potential critic yes
this and this very nice go go go go go
go
is it really i'm so sorry okay no
problem
excuse me yes what's the matter
oh [ __ ]
hey just when it was going perfectly
well the [ __ ] soul comes back when
this came back the only thing that was
running through my head
was whether it was the bone appetit
table
the traditional stuff is very good yeah
chicken parmesan very good we want all
the pastas the pork chops
lambs to give everybody a little taste
you wanted one of each uh-huh okay thank
you okay no problem you're welcome
how did you know it's them uh they
ordered everything on the menu they're
asking questions they're asking
questions they're ordering a lot of wine
that is definitely a food critic anthony
table nine is six people yes one of them
i think is the critic
step it up yeah yes bounce back come on
let's go okay we're gonna do table nine
a very very very important table all
right here we go three minutes on the
pasta tony looking good looking good
anthony yeah what's up risotto yes yes
chef yes hey the most important results
that you've made in your [ __ ] life
look at that huh beautiful cable nine
risotto and ragu i need your second
busboy please quickly
nine please
wow
everything's on the line tonight if we
don't make it then you know it's just
gonna be a disaster
[Music]
that looks lovely it's the relaunch
dinner and tiffany has just delivered
entrees to the editor-in-chief of bon
appetit now all the family can do is
hope i'm very nervous about the critics
i really do think that my business is at
stake tonight it's either going to make
us or break us
to the 5th victoria the fish and the
chicken are really winners thank you and
it's not overcooked no it was nicely
packed
lots of questions and more importantly
they're passing food round which is a
great sign nope not happy with it you
don't pass it how is the best you like
it yeah very good right yes that's a
nice recommendation good thank you
any complaints
no no complaints at all it's great that
they're here you know
fantastic it's amazing it's a dream
beautiful beautiful awesome i was at an
all-time high with bon appetit knowing
that if this positive review comes out
that it's going to put trobianos above
and beyond where we ever imagined with a
wealth of satisfied customers and a good
response from bon appetit trobiano's
relaunch is a success but chef ramsay
knew that anthony still had some
unfinished business
the restaurant's on his way
tonight proved that
but there's one more thing
what is this
[Music]
beautiful wow beautiful
make an honest woman offer
shaken
this is unbelievable this is coming from
you
yeah to us
you've forgotten about it and
if there's one thing that's missing it's
that
and i know personally how long you've
been putting it off because of the
pressure from the restaurant
that
is gonna put an end to it okay yeah
speechless
thank you get up there stand strong
tiffany's a great girl she's put up with
me for the past three years there was no
better time
than tonight to go ahead with this and
ladies and gentlemen i'd like to
introduce you to our chef patron anthony
toriano
i just want to thank everyone for coming
here um you can see we've come a long
way thanks to uh chef ramsay here and
we've moved in such a positive direction
that there's just one thing in my life
that
[Music]
it hasn't been official
tiffany
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i was shocked that anthony proposed to
me in front of everybody it was just
incredible i never expected this in a
million years
i can't believe this
it totally touched me to see anthony
propose a tiffany and i know this is
what he's wanted it's just unbelievable
it's a dream come true you better make
my daughter happy i'll [ __ ] kick your
ass
i have one more
surprise for both of you i've arranged
for both of you to get married tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
we were just totally shocked with all
the excitement of everything else going
on to top it off with a wedding come on
i thought i was gonna die
oh my god this is crazy
i love anthony i've been waiting for
this for six years we have a new life to
start so everything should just fall
into place now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tiffany and anthony have come together
to proclaim their undying love through
the celebration of their marriage
i am filled with so many emotions it was
an amazing night
[Applause]
it's unbelievable there's no other word
to describe all of this really ladies
and gentlemen i just like to say
this
family has been a pleasure to work with
chef ramsey did definitely save our
lives you got to be kidding me if he
didn't come here six months from now
we've probably been close
i'm grateful my family's grateful and i
hope this is a new beginning for all of
us
[Music]
wow amazing i've seen many a dream turn
into a nightmare tonight a nightmare
turned into a beautiful dream
[Music]
you